hello and welcome to this video penguin
master Impaler and it doesn't sound very
nice no name okay I wanted to do
something else here and going 1.e4 let's
see what we get Carol count two nights
it's a pretty decent sideline okay so
what do you see going for simply should
be seven I guess well that's an easy to
play position White has got two bishops
nothing to worry about Black is very
solid but doesn't look too bad uh-huh
okay so Bishop age 6 mm well may I
should have played that one move earlier
right yeah anyway I'm just centralizing
cannot be that bad screen b6 something
to very about after Bishop to g5 and
knight on c3 is not not ideally placed
hmm
yeah I wonder what is the best piece
placement here of course some you can do
simple things and be okay but i think
the night is really misplaced i try to
trade it
loses a bit of time but I want the move
c3 here so that I'm that I'm
conveniently covering things okay well
maybe just a 3-2 slide weakness of the
queenside but how to hard to believe
that this is a real issue yeah probably
he gets he gets you five in here for
equality no that's a pretty clear
equalizer probably okay okay let's go in
there maybe ego ce5 here I don't know
maybe should be six it's not a very
ambitious move of the c5 I just want to
take but I didn't see anything
particularly great either blacks
position is it's just very solid
don't have any particular reason to hope
for something great yeah I know black
can try many things even be five is a
move b5 put a knight on d5 Jim I don't
think he has something particularly
exciting sure that sets an option on
okay let's go back okay don't mind the
trade ya here I think I'm quite
comfortable it doesn't have any
meaningful porn break he solid of course
as we said a couple of times already but
blegh as a hard time doing anything yeah
constructive let's aim
probably all the way back
I can take with the rook of course I'm
just straight trade down everything no
okay it's not a not bad actually check
hmm and I don't think I can do much here
it's got the the more active more active
kind of king a king of 65 should be a
draw I don't think I can try anything
here
impaler it doesn't sound very nice why
don't they call themselves mr. nice guy
or I know mr. happy sunshine or miss
middle little miss sunshine or something
like that isn't Impaler isn't that
pretty nasty okay anyway
yeah I want them safe to see if any
great idea here shooting form what
exactly yeah it is probably just a drone
King to 3f for this g4 that's nothing to
worry about yeah
I said of f3 f4 is a reserve move so
King d6 I guess is what he has to do
so King King King you for king e 6f ok
music is a draw kinky [ __ ] sex King
c5 king e 5 king b 5f for chicks takes
my attempt to slow them i think it is
just a draw actually
time morning I think it's just a Troy
grammas taken them would be able to a
shame but I think it's a draw can you
[ __ ] is 16 25 king e 5 takes it f
four tix King takes King a four well g5
takes txp for h 4head it won't work and
by now i'm down on the clock down time
yeah anyway ha ha oops no we try
something after all right still just a
draw what is this now you want to do so
check check what what we want what
happened here she's awesome draw what
the same time it says chick main and
gamed wrong what kind of nonsense was
that hey Tom I know that was weird at
the end and actually he just gifted me
that point I should have just have to
have taken it it was very strange it was
just just just a complete complete draw
all the way and then he decided to that
you wanted to lose very weird and it's
still a draw but we're taking is his
complete madness yeah I could have taken
myself and keep c5 that wins ok yeah ok
I didn't have much time i know and i was
i was thinking okay it's just a roll
here gets to go back now after age 5 i'm
just winning yeah i was a bit too
relaxed ya think check check yeah i was
just about moving this when I was
stepped the time yeah ok there was not
much much happening in this game to be
perfectly honest deadline is some as I
said it's very solid but um yeah black
doesn't have a hard time here 94 is a
very simple kind of move I wasn't sure
what to do if i go here i was a little
bit concerned about Queen B 6 and now
you know that had anything and I have no
good way to sacrifice a pawn at least I
didn't see it and the night is just off
him it
it I want to have the possibility to go
see three so I went for the trade which
is not pressurizing him much but what's
definitely okay I think we are just
talking about an equal position here and
actually thought I would be a little bit
better but ok it's still so on such a
healthy structure that it's difficult to
get any this was basically trading down
to a draw but then he yeah he gifted me
the point that I didn't take it yeah
somehow are not getting in getting the
right speed at the end ok thanks for
watching